bonjour friends welcome back to the show
it is a 900 000 subscriber q a episode
this one came along quite quickly and as
usual I asked for questions on Instagram
Twitter locals and YouTube community and
there were literally thousands so I've
tried to condense down lots of ones that
were all similar and I'm going to get
through as many as I can today as always
thank you so much for all of the support
I really do appreciate it
um this year has just been insane a
growth the guests the quality of the
conversations everything's amazing so
thank you very much for being a part of
it let us get into it
the Winger 22 what is this product that
you're releasing with James Smith okay
so I flew back to the UK for 44 hours a
couple of weeks ago to finish off the
final versions of something that I've
been working on in secret with James for
six months now we're going to be able to
announce it probably within six weeks or
so early July I think we'll be able to
announce it
and it is so good we've been working so
hard on this we've tested 150 different
variations and
I'm I'm so happy I can't wait to release
this it's also the first product that
I'm ever going to have released and the
first product that James has ever done
the first thing that we've ever probably
put our names behind and we're we're
joining forces like like what who did
who did the Fusion dance in Dragon Ball
Z whoever that was that's like us
Andres koi won who is your current role
model
I think I'm quite fortunate that at the
moment a lot of the people who I used to
idolize are now friends
partly due to living in a place that's
just full of absolute beasts and also
because I do something that I'm also a
fan of I'm a fan of the podcasting
independent thinker space and I also
exist in it as well
um
definitely thinking more and more about
how to be a positive person so guys like
Naval who have a very Rosy outlook on
life who can try and see the good in
what's happening is something that I'm
trying to take more of but honestly
turning Idols into Rivals and then
Rivals into friends is one of the
biggest life hacks ever it's it's
phenomenal to have somebody that you
both respect and admire that is now a
fan of even your work and and you get to
look up to them it's it's really cool
Max podzigan sleep token album thoughts
also your favorite albums of all time
thanks for amazing pod thank you this
new sleep token album take me back to
Eden is out of this world it's probably
one of the best albums I've heard in the
last five years so if you haven't
checked it out you need to go and listen
to it
it's amazing man I mean they've managed
to blend metal with like hip-hop rap
with a funk with this weird Jazz offset
[__] it's it's outstanding I'm very very
impressed uh other favorite albums
um semiternal by Bring Me is outrageous
um I also have a Listen to deadmau5's
album from 2007 uh the one that had more
ghosts and stuff on it uh those would be
two that come to mind
Clancy
that mustache yes
yes I know I don't know I was gonna grow
my hair uh and I literally only got it
cut today I was gonna grow my hair out
because I was getting a bit bored but
it's so hot in Austin that I can't bear
it uh and the mustache I had one of
these during lockdown and I just thought
why not Channel my inner 70s cop slash
porn star so this is what we're playing
with for the time being
Smelly Cat congrats sir well deserved
thank you I feel like you do these 100K
q and A's every month now yep I do uh
that one million episode is coming soon
my question love the Dr K episode you
guys got to talking about Sigma grind
set and survivorship bias and he
mentioned that there are some people
that work that ass off and still fail
maybe for the lack of proper strategy as
someone who put in the work and has
built multiple successful businesses is
it hard for you to concede to the idea
that hard work doesn't always equal
success do you think that there are
people who do the work have the right
strategies even but still for whatever
reason fail or do you think there's
always an observable addressable reason
someone is unable to get to where they
set out to go even in regards to the low
probability of success things like
living off creative Endeavors as you do
that is a really smart question I have
to say as well all of the questions from
today are
so phenomenal do you want to know why
this doesn't feel like the tenor in the
comments more like they're so reasonable
and balanced and smart super super smart
and then sometimes some of these
episodes go hyper viral and it I don't
know it just reaches out into the real
versions of YouTube like the the
Cesspool YouTube and sometimes the
comment sections are just so boring
filled with like I know just negativity
anyway the people that ask questions you
should comment more on YouTube is my
point
um
is it the case that people can work very
hard
and still come out on the other side not
succeeding yeah obviously you know that
you are rolling the dice every single
time that you try and have an
interaction that you try and set out to
achieve some sort of a goal you might
not do it and that is a risk that you
take
it is a difficult Circle to square
because
every single person that I know
who has continued to work hard and is
talented and consistent has achieved
success there's no one that I don't know
so here's a good story
um Kristoff the DJ CJ from um Newcastle
I was with him last weekend he was
playing in Austin I remember we used to
go back to After parties at this guy's
house when we were early 20s or
something and he would
play People songs that he'd produced and
he was in love with Eric pritz and the
prince was his Idol and stuff
and he would bring these tracks in and
play them and some of the guys would be
a little bit mocking like oh you and you
mate Eric have you been speaking much
obviously Eric Prince didn't know who
the [__] this guy was and he would leave
after parties that were in his own
living room to go into the spare bedroom
of his house which was his studio and
make tracks for a couple of hours and
then come back in so he would abandon a
party he was hosting to go play work on
his stuff and then come back in
the guy just didn't stop I remember
thinking at the time this dude is so
talented and hard-working it's it's
simply a matter of time before something
hits and sure enough
all of the people that had sort of given
him a bit of digs about oh you and you
made Eric
I think three or four years ago he
warmed up for Eric Prince at Madison
Square Garden on New Year's Eve and he's
on prider he's on his label he's playing
every Monday at high Ibiza this summer
with Eric and Adam Bayer so if you're in
a beat of this summer you should go and
see Cosby play
um my point being that
sometimes things are not going to work
out even if you have put all of the hard
work in but the more that you are
intentional the more that you work hard
the more that you are consistent the
more that you try and apply reason and
talent to whatever it is that you're
doing that likelihood gets
infinitesimally smaller and smaller and
smaller and then over time you can
basically erode it away to zero I know a
lot of people I know a lot of people who
were successful
all of them are people who have had
failures who have continued to iterate
and then on the other side of that have
been uh have managed to achieve what it
is that they wanted
it is low probability but if you keep
going you you either stop or you win
those are the two solutions
Felix black query query rare
when are you coming to Montreal uh maybe
next year the live tour thing that we're
doing in November hopefully will do
really really well obviously it's all
sold out and stuff which was great
if that goes well and I enjoy it and
it's fun we will do a full Global tour
next year uh Australia there are so many
Aussies uh all of America Canada UK
again and then maybe some places in
Europe so maybe next year
just Joel Williams hi Chris I want to
create a changing career but everyone
around me is telling me not to any
advice
don't listen to them you don't need to
listen to somebody telling you what you
shouldn't do if you want to do it I want
a changing career but everyone around me
is telling me not to just do if if
you've done the assessment and because
you listen to this show you probably
have worked out what you want to want
if the changing career is something not
to being a drug dealer it's presumably
to something which is more aligned more
virtuous more ascended more awakened in
line with what it is that you want to do
in life
just go and do it like you're already
succeeding presumably at a job that you
hate can you imagine how amazing you
would be at a job that you actually
enjoyed
uh so yeah most people's advice isn't
worth listening to you can aggregate it
but I don't know most people are into it
user
922281 why did you ban me from
commenting
Okay so
I mentioned earlier on about the real
internet that you kind of push out into
if anything achieves a bit of virality
you go from outside of the core audience
that the subscribers and the people who
align with what you're doing and you get
out into just like the rest of the
internet right like the general public
of the internet
and I just found that some of the
comments sections were getting boring
and negative and cynical and this toxic
positivity thing that I'm on a flex of
at the moment I'm just bored of it like
I'm bored of all of you every single
person that comments with something
that's knee-jerky unthoughtful not
mediated through any sense of thinking
about what's going on there's no context
and all that you want to do is just I
did some guy before I came on
commented on a a real on a slide that I
put up I wasted two minutes of my life
on another white boy that goes to the
gym I'm like okay you don't get to play
in the playpen like it's my house
you have to behave if you want to come
in here this doesn't mean that everyone
has to be a sycophant I'm fine with
criticism I'm just not fine with retards
that was [__] so it's a one and done
ban policy now on the YouTube it used to
be that if someone had commented a
number of times because you can we can
see on the back end if you click on a
user you can see everything that they've
ever commented on your channel and there
was tons and tons of people it was
always the same offenders commenting
just stupid stuff and after a while I
said to the guys that are looking at the
channel on the back end like look get
rid of people if they're being
consistently just negative and boring
and not adding anything to the
conversation and now it's one and done
and over time the comment section will
be sanitized so just behave this doesn't
mean that you need to agree with me it
means that you need to not be an idiot
so yeah and also like I say everyone
that's contributing here contribute in
the comments more because your guys's
input is way more interesting than what
most of the other comments are
have you thought of building a community
in Discord or something so I've actually
been speaking to a guy who his entire
company builds Discord servers around
communities and there's all layers and
admins and it gamifies stuff
so yeah I have
um if people would like that if they
want more of a community
side of things that's something that I'd
consider doing
um
it's not something I'd thought of before
either a slack or a Discord
mostly because I don't use Discord
myself or I haven't until very recently
when I started doing mid Journey uh and
slack as well I hadn't used until we
started adding some more people into the
team so I would and if people are
interested in that then I know comment
or something and and if there's enough
people we'd consider doing it
how to actually realize that people
don't notice us especially our
appearance as much as we think yeah this
is um
it's got it's obvious philosophically
but kind of hard to deploy in reality I
think you know we are our biology is
created to make us feel concerned about
the Judgment of others this makes sense
ancestrally if you knew 50 people in
your portion of the tribe you need to be
very very careful that you didn't do
something that would make you fall down
the rung of status because status was so
closely associated with your mortality
and with your quality of life and so on
so we are your entire body and
Physiology and mind is designed to make
you unsatisfied and remembering that
makes life make an awful lot more sense
however
you do know that you don't care all that
much about anybody else so why would you
think that anybody else cares that much
about you you're just some random person
walking down the street with tomato
sauce on your top no one remembers no
one cares
for me as somebody that was super
self-conscious throughout [__]
forever
it was just time and attention I think
that was a big part of it realizing that
so much of the stuff that I did was
unnecessarily shaped by the opinions of
people who didn't have an opinion on me
and
I
I really really think that if you
realized how little people care about
your appearance like you know you some
of your favorite friends you're friends
with people not because of the way that
they look but because of the things that
they say whether or not they're good
people whether or not they're
interesting whether or not they're kind
whether or not they're reliable
your appearance doesn't make that much
of a difference I promise
escaping mediocrity IQ or boobs in a
mate how far would you give up
Aesthetics for a smart girl this is an
interesting one because you know
men don't value uh intelligence as much
in a partner this isn't to say that they
don't at all and obviously intelligence
is highly associated with being
interesting and kind in all of the
things I just said we care about in the
people that we want around us
but it's not as important uh and a lot
of guys would happily take like an 80 IQ
girl who had the perfect body uh and not
not convinced that the reverse would be
true
one of the problems you have is that
smart people in general can be more
disagreeable and disagreeability is not
all that enjoyable when it comes to a
relationship so it's not just like you
get either IQ or boobs you don't even
just get boobs right it's like okay has
the boobs come with back problems down
the line as the boobs come with an
increased risk of something else there
is like a polygenic score of everything
I think that it's a balance like uh
fence setting it's a balance
um but
you you can't work out whether or not
you should date somebody who is a 10 out
of 10 but that is a door nail or someone
who's super super smart but you can't
bear to see them naked like evidently
both of those are bad ideas sub
personal preference I suppose that being
said I did once here someone who made a
perfect example of everybody is a boobs
guy until they have sex after which
they're a bum guy basically his argument
was that the utility of a bum is is
greater uh up until it's greater to to
use but boobs are better to look at
I don't know but interesting
nevy 69 what about the podcast with
Andrew Tate uh under house arrest at the
moment and I saw what happened to that
Vice guy who tried to get in I never
said this
never mentioned this on the podcast
before I recorded a podcast with Andrew
Tate
three years ago I think two or three
years ago is in the height of covid
Andrew take welcome to show hello good
to see you good to see you as well man
and we spoke about uh lockdowns concern
about governmental overreach
um he was sort of Waging War against
people that were getting vaccinated at
the time and complying with government
demands and I had to turn the pushback
it was like well-natured but I just
didn't put it out because it would have
got the channel absolutely nuked for
talk of vaccine misinformation it was
when everything was super hot on YouTube
so I texted him afterwards and I was
like mate I can't I can't put this out
because it's just gonna it's gonna
destroy the channel and he understood
and said let's run it back and we can do
a different conversation we can talk
about other stuff
but uh yeah that's just sat on a hard
drive somewhere unreleased Tate content
this is another thing man like
I understand that everybody all of us on
YouTube sell our soul to one degree or
another but there are people out there
like that as an example I could have
released that at the height of Tate's
Fame as some you know unseen unreleased
to our Andrew Tate video it would have
been clipped up to hell it would have
got millions of plays
but I know it just didn't it felt like
it the time had passed for having that
conversation it probably wouldn't have
been a super smart thing to do or it's
super fair thing to do about Andrew
because he his views would have changed
there are people on YouTube that behave
like normal human beings like that's a
normal thing to do it's just fair and
not screwing over somebody I know that a
lot of content creators can seem like
they're just ready to take a bag or to
compromise whatever value and virtue
that they have and that's tempting all
of the time every single day that's
tempting uh but I I do work pretty hard
myself and a lot of my friends do too to
like try and find that balance so have a
bit of faith in your content creative
favorites when you can
Timo shernin
what has been the greatest challenge for
you in monetizing the podcast very
appropriate question
um I mean I largely haven't monetized
the podcast there are people who have
followings
10 of what I do in terms of monthly
reach in terms of subscribers in terms
of impact who make 10 times 100 times
more money I mean 100 but a lot more
money than I do and they've got courses
and educational products and they've
productized commercialized stuff
um I think one of the biggest challenges
has been remaining
aligned with what I want to do I've said
no to so many guests to come on this
podcast that I don't think add any value
to the conversation or I don't think
that they're good actors or I don't
think that they are virtuous people or
I'm just not interested in them and even
though they would have caused tons and
tons of plays
and I'm trying to hold that same level
of
um
value and
Integrity as best I can with monetizing
as well and that means I'm leaving an
awful lot of money on the table like I'm
leaving tons and tons and tons of cash
on the table I'm not monetizing as
effectively as I could be or should be
um so that's been one of them uh
balancing like Integrity with
commercialization
um another one would be that it's a very
heavy lift you know for all that the
channel is massive and channels of this
size usually have a huge team around
them
it's not we've got a new guy uh who has
been with us for about two months now
Chase who is my YouTube Wizard My Little
YouTube dwarf Mage guy like little
spellbinder YouTube person who's bigger
than me and uh he's great but it's still
a very small team which means that
anything that we want to bring to Market
is very effortful so I'm always the
bottleneck for this stuff but I would
love to release some educational
products over the next couple of years
like I'd love to do a morning routine
course a Communications course uh maybe
something to do with networking maybe a
podcast Mastery thing I'd love to get
those out because I think that they're
genuinely aligned with me I don't feel
like I'm selling out it's not a grift or
a shill to teach people the things that
you guys ask every single q a
but it is a heavy lift and I also kind
of don't actually know if you want that
what it is that you want do you want a
Discord Community do you want courses or
whatever so I'm gonna comment I'll find
some way to tell somebody to tell me to
do something maybe we'll do it
Murphy's Law are you going to do a meet
and greet or after party event following
your live shows yes didn't put this on
the advert but yeah we're going to find
a venue for
um after Dublin Manchester and both of
the London shows um and everybody's
going to be invited and I'm going to be
there and some of the like big and end
guests that are just going to come and
sit in the crowd will probably be there
too so we'll be able to catch up and and
every I can meet everybody and I can do
photos and things
um when it shows of this size
most people some people would do VIP
tickets with meet and greet and the
photos and all the rest of this stuff
but I'd rather just meet everyone you
know if we're doing next year shows that
are a thousand fifteen hundred two
thousand cat plus you can't do that but
for now with the shows at the Caps that
they are it's realistic that I can get
through everyone so yes it's the answer
what do you think are the darkest
elements that came out of the manosphere
that is a good question
what do I think are the darkest elements
that came out of the manosphere
I mean some of the fundamental
assumptions
around that philosophy I think are are
quite damaging I think that treating
women as the enemy uh as a resource to
be extracted from or as an enemy to be
used and discarded or avoided at all
costs
isn't a particularly successful approach
for a guy that wants to feel like he is
integrated holistically into the world
around him like you're seeing 50 of
every every single street that you walk
down half of the people that are walking
on that street are either an enemy or a
resource to be extracted from
doesn't exactly make me think that
they're going to be a good person and
it's not like these people arrived at
this conclusion on their own thought
leaders are giving these pieces of
advice out there so that would be one of
them that you've basically demonized 50
of the entire globe
um
I'm not convinced that
teaching men their primary goal is to
become as high value as possible to lean
into discipline and and do all of the
hard things and you've got to be on your
grind and you've got to make money and
you've got to be in shape and all of the
rest of it but that discipline ends at
the boundary around your penis
you can be disciplined in everything in
life but when it comes to women like
just it's a free-for-all bro because
Genghis Khan or something
also doesn't
strike me as a particularly smart idea
like it's just rank hypocrisy isn't it
like if you believe that discipline and
integrity and virtue and doing the right
thing are a smart way to go but you want
to carve out this little niche because
you can't control where your penis goes
and that's not me saying that this is
like something that any guy can do but
if you're going to proselytize about all
of this stuff you need to have a
philosophy that is
um contiguous with that right it needs
to run
at least you need to scale it to your
penis from your bank account to your
pants and I don't know I think those
would be two of them but I mean I'm
writing this book with David at the
moment for people that don't know I'm
writing a book with David Buss the
grandfather of evolutionary psychology
and um it's going to come out soon no
it's not it's going to come out next
year it's going to be finished within
the next six months but I'm balls deep
in all of this research at the moment
trying to work out what's going on with
modern mating deeper than I go on the
show which is pretty deep already and
it's fascinating but it's dangerous like
people aren't being fed particularly
good advice by mainstream media and the
stuff that's on the internet has like
glimmers of gold in piles of [__] so
really trying to dig into that is
proving difficult I would say those two
things adversarial nature between men
and women uh seeing them as an enemy to
be avoided or as a an adversary to be
used and discarded
um and this
lack of
um discipline across all areas of your
life I think two not particularly
positive Concepts
wizard Wow have you had guests cancel
last minute and suspected or knew that
it was due to them maybe learning about
problematic guests you had on the show
before
never I would say either never well I
guess how would I know I've not
suspected it ever uh happening and
certainly not recently I don't think
I've had that many problematic people on
the show like
you know the most problematic guests are
people like Carl Benjamin Sargon of a
cad he's up there I guess Jordan
Peterson if you don't like him David
Pacman would be problematic for a lot of
people from the right
um I don't know I I think that most
people seem to be quite reasonable
around people that you've had on
especially if you seem to be acting in
good faith so far I appear to be doing
it
Nick O'Neill what software do you use to
record the podcast remotely do you have
any recommendations on how to optimize
audio quality when recording remote
interviews through Zoom or Microsoft
teams critical Drinker sorted me out
with this I was having a bit of a
nightmare recording uh remotely and he
got me onto stream yard you need to get
stream yards whatever the big dick
biggest biggest biggest dick platform is
before you go to like teams and
Enterprise and all that it's like Pro or
platinum or something and you can do
local both ends recording audio and
video separate tracks 1080p locally
recorded and uploaded and it's all
hosted in a back end that everybody can
access you can delegate user profiles
and it's brilliant so stream yard
samsi have you ever considered going on
Russell Brand's podcast or having him on
the show he's just put the video out on
population collapse and I can imagine
you having a really interesting
conversation with him I would love to
speak to Russell Brand about population
collapse he has gone especially during
covet it was a bit like you don't know
that they're coming for you you won't
believe that what they said about your
children's vaccine stated like it was
all kind of a bit uh like if the sun
made a a YouTube channel but he seems to
have dialed it back which is good and
the population collapse video that he
did was with my friend Stephen Shaw the
guy that I broke on this podcast a
couple of months ago so uh for as long
as he's supporting Stephen [__]
brilliant population collapse
fascinating topic Russell Brown
generally genuinely interesting fella a
little bit tough to get a hold of so I
need an intro to him if you known
Russell Brand
loot me in that'd be great Holly
Robinson I think I'm too late to ask a
question for the Pod no you're not but
two guests suggest suggestions Brett
Contreras aka the glute God not familiar
with him but he sounds interesting Parma
lucky I did a uh
I did a podcast at Parma looky's house
actually so I've met him uh pameloki's
interesting dude he's got like this
military
Wing thing that he does and he was the
guy that founded Oculus and sold it to
Facebook he's pretty cool
M Siddharth 9080. what do you think
about Indian foods phenomenal but hard
to find good quality Indian food in
Austin
authentic
VI vibhav how is it like being you I
think you mean what is it like being you
um it's pretty fun at the moment I think
my life if people got to see what my
day-to-day life looks like they would
probably be quite surprised it's very
regimented very normal like kind of
boring for the most part
um there's
it's interspersed with cool stuff right
like last night I got to go to the
comedy Mothership uh and went in and got
to see Mark Normand and chilled out and
caught up with him because he'd been on
the show on Wednesday or you know today
Bill Perkins the guy that wrote uh die
with zero I get to go out in his boat
but for the last full week basically all
that I've done is go from here where
I've recorded a podcast to the place I
sit and work in my house looking over my
garden
answering emails doing calls organizing
stuff trying to integrate this like
growth for the team so that I don't need
to do this all the time so it's it's fun
but kind of repetitive and um I'm
looking forward to having like having
more fun in my life because it's been
I've grinded a lot since I got to Austin
so I think it's time for me to
maybe let go of some of that he says as
he begins to embark on writing a book
Cade Derbyshire do you think we'll react
too slowly to population collapse
that's a good question
reacting too slowly to stop it yes I
think that we're already rolling down
the hill and I think that we're probably
going to get
at least below
5 billion maybe below like four
um
what you are going to see though is a
rapid diminishing of particular groups
of people particular sort of demographic
groups so uh white liberals for instance
are kind of going to be eradicated by
population collapse because they're not
having children so who do you think are
going to be the white liberals in future
now don't say that it's supposed to be
the case that we're supposed to have a
society filled with white liberals
but if you care about liberal values and
that's something that you want to
propagate into the future and you're not
having kids you are ending not only your
own genetic line but also your own
cultural line and your own political
line
um so what you're going to end up with
are a rapid proliferation of groups like
uh Orthodox religious fundamental
religious groups so
um Mormons Jews Orthodox Jews especially
um like Roman Catholics Christians and
Christian sects and stuff like that so
those are going to be the ones that are
going to grow which is interesting so
it's like will you react too slowly to
population collapse over time I think
that a true true existential risk I
don't think population collapse is
but it's going to be shitty on the way
down it's going to be shitty while we're
there and it's going to lose not like
biodiversity but um like human diversity
actually is going to decline an awful
lot because the sort of groups that
don't reproduce are going to be the sort
of groups that don't reproduce which
means that Downstream from that there
are fewer of them to make fewer of them
to make fewer of them meanwhile other
groups are going to make more of them to
make more of them so if you care about
having a diverse population which
everybody who
doesn't care about population collapse
says that they are you need to have kids
[Music]
what is the best way to become an
articulate and eloquent person
I get asked this question a lot and just
intentionality I think is the most
important thing
think about what you're going to say be
precise with your speech practice it if
you can record it listen back to
yourself and work out what the twerks
and tweaks and ticks that you have are
that you don't like
get rid of them go again
working with a speech coach that I have
done and I still do and I will be doing
in the build up to my performance at the
end of the year for the live tour
it's honestly like
what brand of protein powder do you use
in order to get big as opposed to did
you go to the gym five times are you
eating your Macros are you getting
enough protein into your diet are you
having your protein shake like the brand
of protein [__] it's the top five
percent that was The Leverage almost all
of it was just reps spending time and
attention
that's the way to go
Russ brooch just buzzed my hair similar
to yours good work uh do you like it for
confidence reasons
it's convenience reasons to be honest uh
not having to do your hair is a life
hack it's hot here in Austin it's the
reason I just got it cut from like that
long down to however short it is now uh
and I had a massive afro for almost 10
years so I've I've served my time with
long hair
good art soup what is the field that
you're interested in but I haven't
covered yet in the podcast so I think
that
um the existential risk of AI is
something that I'd love to revisit given
that we've got this
language learning model chat GPT gpt4
gpt5 thing coming down the pike
um I think now is the time to really
sink back into that I was obsessed by it
for a while when I first read super
intelligence by Nick Bostrom and now
I've got all of the market in the world
to talk about this with and um yeah I'm
going to have
Tristan Harris I texted him a couple of
days ago the guy that did the social
Dilemma on Netflix texted him he's Keen
to come on at some point Jeffrey Miller
is going to come on and do a primer so
that all of you guys can understand the
entire landscape of what we're talking
about how AI could be an X risk and then
I've got uh Katya
Grace maybe who's an AI researcher that
William mccaskill introduced me to so
I've got a ton of different people that
I'm gonna kind of try and fold together
and really just work out okay how big of
a problem is this what are the ways it
could go wrong what are the ways it
could go right what do we need to do to
protect ourselves what can we do
ourselves to influence the way that this
field moves forward
so that probably AI
Kieran Comey coach uh very excited to
come to your money event later this year
how will it be structured uh so I think
it's going to be similar to the 14
lessons from 2022 style episode so you
know segments of me telling stories
insights from those stories
um hopefully there'll be some production
that we can tie into that to make it
feel a little bit more immersive maybe
some music I might be speaking to mark
from after school or someone similar to
get some visuals that can kind of
accompany what we're doing I did this I
you might not have seen But I narrated a
story for after school which is really
cool it's called
um
the slow drip of endless fantasy I think
and uh
I really enjoyed it and I thought that
it drove the point home in a way that me
just telling you a thing can't so I'm
going to try and have some of the
philosophy Bros stuff a little bit of
jokes and and personal stories
um some really tactical takeaways you
know how to apply this and then some
super uh inspirational points that will
tie in with
some performance Arty musicy stuff too
should be really fun I'm just going to
kind of test the water and see
what works what resonates and then from
there you know come 2024 if we do a
really bigger tour I'll have got a good
bit of like right wow all of that stuff
worked or this is really great and this
we can switch or whatever else it's
gonna be cool I'm really excited
reluka fan chewy fenachio no question I
just love you thank you I love you too
uh keep the fire burning we are doing
good to the world trying
call Campbell what is the biggest
sacrifice you make behind the scenes to
make modern wisdom what it is I think
it's what I said earlier on that
um life
takes a big hit like you know I'm not
a lumber worker right with a
90 out of a thousand chance of
mortality per year or something like I
don't I don't lose 10 of my friends to
work accidents every single 365 days but
it is consistent it is hard work it is
grind like there's a lot that I put in
and it does
like it is sapping sometimes and it's
all me right there's no boss there's no
one to step in
and to make this work uh become harder
uh uh becoming easier sorry there's no
one else that's going to come in and
help and do it if I don't do it it's not
going to get done if I don't find the
guest if I don't schedule him if I don't
research them it's not going to happen
which is fine that's the price that I
chose to pay and I love the like
show itself
but there's an awful lot that goes on to
like just buttress it and keep it going
and it's getting more there's more and
more and more stuff that needs to be
done all of the time to keep the show
going so I'm looking forward to Growing
the operation to the point where I can
kind of just get back to only doing the
stuff that I'm really really good at
which is conversations researching
that's it cuppy do you ever feel like
your head is going to explode with all
this information you take in all the
time and if so how do you process all of
this and make sure important lessons
aren't forgotten okay so Chris Bott came
back I spoke to the team that made it
and actually made an upgraded version
2.0 that is less uh switzerlandy to sit
on the friends is it Belgium or
Switzerland whoever it is anyway it's
like more me supposedly so let's see do
you feel like your head is going to
explode with all this information you
take in all the time and if so how do
you process all of this it makes your
important lessons aren't forgotten Chris
bot don't be a cook ha I'm not sure if
my head is going to explode but I do
feel like I'm constantly learning and
growing I'm always looking for new ways
to process and store information and I'm
constantly challenging myself to think
out the box I'm also a big believer in
taking notes writing things down so I
can refer to them later this way I can
ensure that I'm not forgetting anything
important
that's not far off
that's not far off at all I do take a
lot of notes
um
and you'll hear me in episodes sometimes
refer to them I'll bring up some quote
that I'm trying to find and I'll just
tap tap tap tap tap away and then
it comes up processing it and making
sure that the lessons aren't forgotten
I've said this before it's I have to
teach it I have to recall it to people
on an episode with a guest or in the
newsletter or on a tweet or when
somebody asks me just day to day during
conversations I'm always recalling
information you have to remember that
learning and memorization does not come
from repeated exposure it comes from
repeated recall you have to recall this
stuff if you're not recalling it you're
not going to learn it like repeated
exposure means nothing repeated recall
is what matters
Hyundai Daniel recently started watching
a podcast you're a huge inspiration to
me thank you any advice for a 20 year
old who doesn't know what the [__] to do
with his life Chris Bott let's see if
you've got anything to say for this
gentleman who doesn't know what the [__]
to do with his life
come on now respond
you cook
my advice would be to take some time to
explore and find out what you're
passionate about don't be afraid to take
risks and try new things you have plenty
of time to figure out what you want to
do so don't be afraid to take food a few
details along the way life is all about
learning and growing so don't be afraid
to make mistakes and learn from them
also not bad from chrispot there
um I would say
explore before you exploit so you can go
and travel to a new country try
something different go and work abroad
for a year don't be scared about taking
risks you've got basically nothing to
lose because you haven't accumulated
anything yet there is going to be a
point in your life in 10 or 20 or 30
years time where you have tons of
responsibility and restrictions and you
can't go and do this anymore so allow
yourself to do the things now that you
are only going to be able to do now and
that includes when I was 22. I went and
did the season in Ibiza and it was maybe
two months or something there and I came
back and I'd lost like 12 IQ points and
had just partied for the entire time but
it was fun and I'm not going to do that
now I'm not going to go and do the
season of the beta now so there are
certain things that you can only do that
you can only experience Adventures that
you can have learnings that you can gain
at certain periods of your life so what
are those now how can you go and explore
expose yourself to different things
different people different cultures
different languages different adventures
and you will discover especially if
you're a reflective person which it
sounds like you are you're going to
discover so much about yourself during
that process
just keep on exploring and eventually
you'll find the thing that you're
looking for
the benass podcast proud to say I've
been around since day one almost dear
God thank you I I apologize uh the
progression has been absolutely
ridiculous in the most positive sense
doing three a week like clockwork
deserves all the praise possible thank
you I'm wondering how you learned to
allocate your time to everything and how
rigorous you are with your schedule
there has to be a ton of hard days in
between it has to be a ton of hard days
in between keep rocking but thank you
I'm not that I'm not that like rigorous
with the schedule in that there's no
calendar but I do just try and do the
same things each day of each week so
Mondays we sit down we go through Clips
we make sure that the full weekly
YouTube schedule has been lined up I'll
do prep for all of the guests and I'll
try and check in on emails Tuesday
Thursday Friday I'll try to record
Wednesday is publish day so that's full
day running through titles intros
thumbnails descriptions everything for
the coming up week then record intros
record ad reads uh deal with advertisers
make sure that everything's sorted there
and then weekends do the newsletter try
and have some time to myself uh and then
run it back from Monday so I've kind of
outsourced a lot of what I do to just
routine but it's not like it's a
rigorous schedule I don't have some you
know very carefully put together
calendar that's keeping me accountable
because as a disciplinarian I'm kind of
[__] but as a habit follower I'm
actually really good and I think that
this is you know the other side of
talking about discipline that discipline
can be made much more easy if you turn
things into habits but because
having to rely on anything that isn't
discipline like you know discipline
needs motivation for breakfast which I
don't disagree with
having to rely on anything that isn't
discipline makes it sound like you're
undisciplined but you might as well just
use less discipline if you can and
relying on routine is one of those
strategies that I think that you can use
Alex Davidson why are you so interested
in the facts surrounding how a majority
of men struggle to attract women when
you yourself are well outside of that
demographic I imagine that for men that
are in that demographic listening to you
talk about that polite is a bit like a
billionaire explaining how much poverty
sucks to a homeless person you're good
looking and successful so why are you
fascinated the average guy's dating
struggles I'm looking forward to your
million Mark man I think your show is
underrated keep up the good work
that's a very good question a tough bit
of pushback but also a [__] sandwich to
make me feel nice at the end that's the
sort of comment that is critical but
acceptable
on the podcast Channel um
the analogy between me being like a
billionaire explaining how much poverty
sucks to a homeless person if I wasn't
successful and I wasn't good looking and
I was talking about the plight of men
people would accuse me of just being
bitter
even though I'm not those things and I
talk about them
I'm accused of being out of touch so
it's a very difficult like it's
unfalsifiable really for me to talk
about I can either be in that cohort and
be accused of being a misogynistic incel
Psy boy or I can be outside of it and I
can be accused of being like a Bourgeois
opulent lapa so
I think the reason that I do it the
reason that I'm interested in it is
because any topic that is not being
discussed by the mainstream media but
needs to be discussed
because it's affecting people's lives
what am I doing with an independent
platform if things that interest me and
that I care about and that are
underrepresented that I don't bother
talking about them
um
I do think that there is value in
hearing from people who are on the
ground experiencing this sort of stuff
but
I don't know like do you why do people
follow guys that are in shape when
they're learning how to get in shape is
that not like saying well this guy's
genetically gifted or he's on steroids
or he has been training for longer than
me so what's the point in learning from
them
I'm not too sure uh the guys that are in
that demographic that want to hear from
anybody talk about the plight of of men
they can go to any channel that they
want you know there's wheat waffles
that's like a black pill content creator
who is still on the come up and doesn't
consider himself to be that good looking
so they can go and listen to him if they
want but
I don't know like the billionaire
explaining poverty to to a homeless
person I would like to think it's a
little bit more like the billionaire
saying to the world we should care about
homelessness and dedicating a good bit
of his time to trying to raise people
out of it and also to give awareness to
the world that poverty is something that
we should care about I'd like to think
that that's the the approach that I'm
doing if it does appear like I'm just
some like Bourgeois lapa laughing from
his high horses he doesn't deal with any
of the problems that the normal world
has to deal with I'm not convinced that
that's true and also I hope that it's
not the case because I genuinely do care
I do care about both men and women
anybody that's suffering man like for
all that
the Fiat 500 drivers of the internet
don't think that this is the case
I am a really really empathetic person
like massively to a fault to the point
where it makes me make decisions
incredibly slowly I massively regret
things that I say to people even small I
I there's comments I've made over the
last year that I can't stop thinking
about because I'm like terrified that it
makes me into a piece of [__] even
though it's just some passing joke that
I made or a bit of banter that the other
person is never going to remember
I care about anybody that's suffering
and especially people that are suffering
that are being ignored by the mainstream
I think that it's a good investment in
my time I appreciate the question it's a
really good question
Johnson uh
I'm 13 years old
interested in business and I go to the
gym what do you recommend I do to
acquire more knowledge and invest in my
future
dear God man this is the second time in
a row now
a child
who watches this podcast has come on and
asked questions around business and and
personal development and stuff first off
massive massive props to you being
someone who is
just under a third of my age and is
asking yourself questions that most
people my age haven't got around to
asking themselves yet congratulations
secondly I don't mean to be patronizing
but
experiencing life and just allowing
yourself to indulge in uh social
situations exposing yourself to as many
different experiences as possible will
be the highest leverage thing that you
can do with regards to your learning
like there is so much unrealized wisdom
and insight that you can tap into by
just experiencing the day-to-day
like vicissitudes of being a human
because you haven't had a massive amount
of it yet that you're going to capture a
lot of that so
I would be very cautious around going
monk mode at age 13 focusing on reading
all of the books you can and spending
your time in the gym with your
headphones in listening to sleep tokens
new album
I would
spend time probably around people that
are older than you if you can get in
with good well-meaning 15 16 17 year
olds that'll take you under their wing
you've got to be careful they're not
going to you know take you down a dark
path but
you're basically
13 years ahead of your 13 year old self
so finding people that are a bit older
would be a big help uh
if you are serious about trying to
maximize the time that you spend in
terms of understanding knowledge and
investing in your future in
find the content creators that resonate
with you the most listen to them consume
that stuff read however you feel is
appropriate
and then apply that to life like don't
don't be too concerned about starting a
business at age 13 unless there is some
Niche that you know that you can nail
and you have a competitive Advantage
living life exposing yourself to your
content and then going and applying that
day to day would be great but dude
you're going to be
a beast you're gonna be a monster like
you're going to be phenomenal as long as
you don't knock yourself off so
keep going
do you have advice for someone who wants
to start a podcast but don't feel
qualified none of us are qualified
nobody started a podcast and was
qualified there is no podcasting
qualification when I started doing this
the first ever episode was me in my old
studio with a single Blue Yeti attached
to the middle of the desk that made tons
of noise and I kept saying every three
seconds and it was filmed on an iPhone
and the guy's girlfriend was in the
corner of the room
and that's it and now we reach like
hundreds of millions of people every
single year so you don't need to worry
about the qualification and
no one's watching you when you start
doing something people that have a fear
that when they start doing something
they're going to suck and the people
that are watching them are going to
laugh at them the beautiful thing is no
one's watching so few people know that
you're doing the thing that no one is
there to watch how much you suck at
doing the thing
there is no pressure you can just start
how can a more traditional woman who
wants to be pursued be more proactive in
her love life that is a cool question
Chris bot
come on red pilled Chris bot this is the
newly ascended hardcore
4chan Chris bot how can a more
traditional woman who wants to be
pursued be more proactive in her love
life
hmm that's a tough one good start I'm
not sure I'm the best person to answer
that question I mean I'm a guy so I'm
not sure I'm the best person to give
advice on how to be pursued
are you saying that I'm not pursued but
if I had to guess I'd say the best way
for a traditional woman to be more
proactive in her love life to make sure
she's putting herself out there go to
events join clubs and make sure you're
meeting new people that way you can
increase your chances of meeting someone
who is interested in pursuing you
that's not bad this is kind of this is a
lot more like me now I think
um one other thing that you could do and
we're writing about this in the book at
the moment is uh cultivating as a woman
cultivating openness and friendliness so
in a post metoo World
86 of women say that they want a man to
make the first move but around about 50
of men say that they are terrified of
making the first move for being seen as
creepy around about
20 of American Millennials and gen
zedders say that a man asking a girl out
on a date asking a girl out for a drink
in person always are usually constitutes
um not abuse but like
um it's overbearing and shouldn't be
done so you have a world in which guys
are seeing anything that resembles a no
as a hell no but girls who still want to
be approached so guys are scared of
approaching girls want to be approached
but are terrified of being physically
abused by some like random man on the
street and like that just causes neither
of them to ever open up so the goal for
guys is to cultivate a sense of
overcoming approach anxiety while still
being safe and respectful to women and
on the woman's side it's important for
them like this is a takes two to tango
scenario the woman needs to be open and
friendly they need to be receptive to
the guys that they want to hear from you
know if you give off a y mantle of
[__] Vibe or like a treat him like
you don't like him thing he's not going
to come over so that would be
a good way you know a more traditional
woman who wants to be pursued and be
more proactive you don't necessarily
want to be uh doing the short skirt and
Tinder thing
but you also still need to up your
chances
Chris Bott got it right you know attend
places and go to events and join clubs
where you will be around the sort of man
that you want to date and while you are
there cultivate receptiveness openness
friendliness I think that'll work in
did you think that you're going to get
this big that's a good question
um me and Dean always said you know even
when we I remember we were episode like
40 or something and I remember saying
[__] dude I can't believe that more
people I'm watching and more people
aren't listening because I think this
stuff's really interesting and he said
yeah me too it's really really cool and
strange isn't it it just hasn't sort of
kicked in yet
we've been saying and doing the same
thing for five years now like some of
the stuff that I put out on Instagram
that went that goes super super viral is
[__] that I've been saying for half a
decade and it's just now that there's
enough people to listen or because of
I guess like
um
the skewed perception of status changing
how people perceive the thing that you
say like that me five years ago didn't
have the same Authority as me now
therefore basically the words that I say
even if they're the same are essentially
different
um
not much has changed it's just been the
same conversations the same curiosity
and
I don't know I I'm very very happy at
how the growth is going I want to change
the day-to-day experience that I have of
it because it's such a heavy lift but
it's a price that I'm willing to pay and
it's not going to be like that forever
and
for as long as we keep accumulating
awesome people that ask questions like
this I'm happy Matt Lake what was the
hardest period slash worst phase of your
life that you have managed to overcome
um I don't think there's been a
particular individual period of time but
there was a chunk
a number of chunks during my 20s where I
was very regularly
um depressed down
spending days in bed I'd struggle to get
out of bed
and make excuses about not attending
meetings and it would make me feel very
uh like ashamed of myself and
that was born out heavily of a poor
sleep pattern and I wasn't eating
amazingly but it was mostly sleep I
think and not connecting and not being
true to the people that were around me
and that took a long time and like every
end of September for probably five years
I basically had a breakdown a miniature
breakdown because I'd worked so hard I'd
invested all of this emotional energy
into running the events and then at the
end of freshers week at the end of the
second freshest week it was to run for
two weeks sometimes for three weeks
I'd just break down and I'd spend a few
days in bed feel like
absolute waste man and then drag myself
back and restart the engine and then go
again and it was that was just this
cycle that I go through so probably that
and um you know
kovid wasn't great for a lot of things
and I don't like the fact that it
destroyed and destroyed it paused the
business that I'd spent a decade
building
uh more than a decade but
it was good to teach me what a stable
sleep and wake pattern feels like and to
also give me an insight into a different
kind of life outside of that
Paul nadiris need a blue modern wisdom
hoodie in my wardrobe when are they out
so
I've wanted to do merch for ages I've
had a ton of conversations with merch
companies but I'm not going to put out
anything that isn't awesome because
first off I've waited for ages and
secondly if it's not nice you're not
going to wear it and thirdly I want to
wear it so it needs to be good we are
sampling a million different versions of
t-shirts and hoodies and everything and
it'll be out 100 before the live tour
because we need merch for the live tour
but
soon hopefully will it be blue I don't
know if it'll be blue maybe navy blue
makes it sound too blue but Navy for
sure
Luke blight thoughts on cutting out
alcohol and the implications it has on
socializing so
I'm a massive proponent of going
elective sobriety uh I've done lots and
lots of periods of it the implications
it has on socializing
the gains that you'll accrue by spending
time around people that you genuinely
are interested in and you don't need to
sedate yourself out of the experience of
being around is priceless for me now
half a debt more than half a decade like
six or seven years into playing with
sobriety and using it as a tool uh I do
think that right now for where I'm at
socializing is more important than being
sober but you don't need to drink to
socialize does it make you less
confident yeah a little bit does it mean
that you're going to want to go home at
one in the morning as opposed to three
in the morning yeah but that's a good
thing nothing fun has ever happened on a
night out after one in the morning right
I know I'm the night out guy right I
have a sample size of a thousand club
nights nothing good happens after one in
the morning so I There is almost almost
no reason that if you've never gone
sober and you live this sort of life
that most people do
the kind of drinking patterns that most
young people do in the west there is no
reason not to go sober I can't think of
a good reason if you've never done it
before
uh what does Chris Bott say about this
I've been sober for a thousand days now
and it's been a wild ride was sober for
a thousand days was a
vanilla ride I've noticed that I'm more
productive I make fewer bad decisions
and have more money in my pocket correct
I also make I'm also more selective of
the people I hang around with because I
don't have alcohol to bond over that
said I'm still finding ways to fun uh
have fun and socialize without alcohol
it's all about finding the right people
and activities that don't involve
drinking all of this is correct
socializing doesn't just mean going on a
night out thanks Chris but doesn't just
mean going on a night out you can do
stuff during the day go and see some
live music go and see a comedy show go
and do you support any there's a million
things that don't involve that but it's
it's a marker of how ingrained and
embedded alcohol is into our culture
that people immediately as soon as you
say socializing oh it's in a bar oh
alcohol's involved so finding a group of
people who don't need to drink to have
fun and that you don't need to drink to
be around that's the life hack
Gary F I'd love to see a behind the
scenes of how you make your shows you
must have a big team working for you uh
there's not much to see man like this is
It's kind of come up a few times today I
haven't really spoken about it before
but
the process of making modern wisdom is
for the most part
very
unspectacular it's me with
notes and and documents and books and
videos just frantically reading them all
and listening to them all and trying to
work out what I want to talk about and
then a couple of other people doing
things Ben Dean and Chase
Chase Wizards YouTube wizard is helping
to take a lot of work off my hands
Dean's always done the stuff that he's
done and then Ben picks up all of the
rest of the bits
it's not very spectacular
um that may change and hopefully will do
uh but yeah it's the behind the scenes
would be like the the least
what you expect and what you would be
delivered would be so disappointing I
don't think that it's going to be
worthwhile um it would be cool to do one
of the big episodes that we have you
know like in other Goggins or whatever
when we we've got a few of those coming
up soon
um that's fun but for the most part I I
walk from that house to this house it's
come and stand in here and make sure
that I have a drink and then I start
talking and then I go back in there and
I upload everything and then an episode
appears it's it's not very exciting
Bailey Magie what is your next uh what
is your end goal what's the next 10
years of Chris Williamson look like see
if Chris bot comes up with something
that I'm going to answer it
while he talks
um end goal I don't have one I just want
to keep on having interesting
conversations it's been the way that
it's always been find people I'm
interested in talk to them about the
stuff that I'm interested in that's it
the next 10 years of Chris Williamson
I if I don't do something catastrophic
and put my foot in my mouth or get
canceled or say something stupid that I
don't mean
it really does feel like the world's at
my feet and it's I said it at
um my birthday Michael malice very
kindly ran a birthday party for me a few
months ago and I said you know it it
literally feels like I can do anything
and it's beautiful and I've never felt
this way before that I have every door
open to me every opportunity is coming
my way and I get to pick and choose what
it is that I want to do and I get to
hopefully like make the world a better
place along with it like I'm not kidding
myself I'm not going to be remembered in
100 years time
but I can nudge the civilization that
I'm a part of even the tiny tiny tiny
degree I can give it a little nudge and
the people that are here at the same
time as me hopefully I can make their
existence in their time on this planet
make a little bit more sense and be a
bit more enjoyable while they're here
[__] like
that's pretty cool like it's pretty cool
as a day today
Chris Bart what'd you say my end goal is
to maximize my freedom to do the things
I want all the time that's pretty
hedonistic I want to be able to wake up
in the morning and decide what I want to
do with my day and if there are things I
don't necessarily want to do that's not
strictly untrue I want to be able to get
them done quickly so they don't take up
too much of my time I also want to make
sure that I don't fall into the Trap of
productivity dysmorphia where I can't
see the fruits of my labors on a daily
basis
this crispot is like this is
overconfident crispart so we come from
cooked crisp or cooked pot to confident
bot now
um
cool I mean it's he's not far off but
some of that stuff I don't think that's
what productivity dysmorphia means and I
made it up uh Omar
cerealtelli are you taking steroids no I
am not and I would be in significantly
better condition if I was
Tommy Conde you get asked every q a
intro song please right I did it I
actually saw this come up and I I went
and I found it it's called Chris talk
Fly Away the JPB remix and Chris is
k-r-y-s talk Fly Away the JPB remix I
listened to this earlier on today before
I came and recorded
listening to that song will make your
head fall off because you if you're
listening to this on Spotify or apple
podcasts have heard it tons of times I'm
you know it's been played Millions tens
of millions of times that song
as an intro an edit that I got my friend
to make a DJ friend to make five and a
half years ago
and then you hear the full version of
the song and all of this extra [__]
appears and you go no no he's supposed
to say like such and such welcome to the
show hang on no this this isn't this
isn't where it's supposed to stop
there's all of this extra stuff it's
like The Uncanny Valley but for
listening so yeah Chris talk Fly Away
the JPB remix it's available on YouTube
uh it's Creative Commons licensed free
which is why we used it and then I got
someone to edit it and it's the both
intro and outro the actual outro to the
song with that the episode of that big
long swell is the breakdown from the
episode that you should be able to hear
actually
um but yeah that's that's it go go and
enjoy and break your brain
if I want to get fit I go to the gym
consistently if I want a girlfriend what
do I do what's my gym [__] good
question that's a smart nice question I
like that you are smart people if I want
a girlfriend what do I do what's my gym
well the gym can be your gym for this
and you know this is common wisdom from
me go to the place where the kind of
people that you want to date
hang out
are you into girls that train you need
to be in a gym a gym that's social would
be a great idea so something like a
crossfit or a boot camp or any kind of
team sport like
[__] me the the fields near where I live
they do kickball which looks like the
lamest sport I've ever seen in my entire
life and yet while the guys and the
girls stood waiting to kick the ball the
dudes are chatting up the girls so I'm
thinking well it's a co-ed spot it's not
actually that dumb of a way to meet
girls apart from the fact that every
girl that goes there knows that you're
the sort of guy that plays kickball so
you know
um other things if you're into acting or
improv or art or whatever it is there
are social groups that exist in the real
world
where other people into the things that
you're into go to
if you're talking about
how do I progress
how do I uh improve the constituent
parts of my personal development in the
same way as going to the gym makes you
fitter what is the progression place
that you do if you want to get a
girlfriend it's just reps right it's
just interacting with girls Destiny's
got this great piece of advice where he
says you just need to have lots of
girlfriends that you spend time around
and that's a really underrated piece of
advice because
good example only child never was
friends with a girl that I didn't want
to bang ever
was because I didn't have a sister like
I guess apart from my mum I didn't have
a sister I didn't have any girl friends
in my life so for me from as soon as I
was 14 15 16. all of the girls I was
hanging around with I were just girls
that I was attracted to
but you lose out on a lot of the uh
understandings that you gain from just
how to interact with girls which is
different to how you interact with guys
so yeah I think hanging around in a
place that's got goals that you don't
need to be trying to get with and just
being okay with that and knowing that
they'll be okay with that and knowing
that you don't come across creepy and
just learning how to communicate
that's the Lion's Share of what you're
talking about I think Spooner Shawn
what's one question that hasn't been
asked in the Q a that you wish somebody
would have asked is there a topic that's
bubbling up in your mind right now
whether you haven't got the chance to
Deep dive on publicly because the right
question or guest hasn't landed recently
this is like the solution to Super
intelligence from Nick Bostrom it's
called machine extrapolated volition so
basically if you can't get if you can't
work out what it is that you want a
machine to do you ask the machine what
it should want to do if it was to detect
all of your preferences uh Chris but I'm
asking him this hmm that's a tough one
yeah correct no [__] I'm always thinking
about new topics and ideas but I'm not
sure I have a specific question I'm
waiting to be asked I guess I'm just
waiting for the right opportunity to
come on
cockbot and confidence bot merging
together here
um not really man like I I talk for so
many hours every single day uh there
isn't anything there isn't it's
something that I haven't been asking and
you don't know what you don't know right
so I will wait and Sean and a bunch of
the other people from the locals
regularly ask phenomenal questions so
relying on them to come up with one
zohib city do you have any advice for
someone who is trying to find good ways
of taking knowledge they have collected
over time and incorporating it into
their daily life thanks and I love your
podcast to keep up the great work Chris
so this
mental masturbation concern thing is
something that I feel in myself as well
and I know that a lot of people that
listen to podcasts and consume lots of
content do because you are exposed to
way more content than you have time to
implement it and you get the illusion of
progress by exposing yourself to more
stuff and more stuff and more stuff and
then you look at your life and you
realize I haven't changed anything who
got exposed to all of this new
information and what have I done
differently in my life oh I haven't
changed anything so avoiding mental
masturbation and the illusion of
progress is very important
doing it requires narrowing down all of
the different areas that you're trying
to change it because you can't change
everything at once and if you try to
you're going to get nowhere right you
have to sacrifice meaning you have to
sacrifice progress toward everything in
the short term to make meaningful
progress toward any one thing so
forget worrying about all of the other
stuff focus on I'm just going to work on
dialing in diet and training for the
next month and I'm going to learn as
much as I can and I'm going to try and
apply it and be as applicable as I can
and once I've built up a little bit of
momentum with those then maybe I'll
switch to some productivity stuff and
then maybe I'll switch to something else
as well when I look back I realize that
a lot of the times I stopped making
progress or when I took my eye off the
ball of something that was an obvious
goal and then tried to Pivot so there's
a period where I was obsessed with
productivity the start of this podcast
so obsessed with productivity for ages
and ages and I'd capped out I'd already
completed I'd accumulated all of the
information that I needed and I presumed
that more productivity was just
the next YouTube video or the next
productivity hack away and it wasn't I'd
already done that so it's like okay I've
done this thing I've completed it let's
move on to the next one I can come back
to it in future so I would narrow down
the sort of things that you're doing I
would try and be as applicable as
possible and I would ask myself when I'm
reading or watching or consuming
anything how am I supposed to apply this
to my life what's the way to get
tactical with all of this stuff you
listen to an entire podcast that I have
with some guy take one thing away from
it one how can I apply this to my life
what should I do try and habitize it try
and make it into a routine
that should make a good bit of of impact
but it's it's a um it's a disciplining
of not doing more
or it's a it's a disciplining of
restriction as opposed to a disciplining
of abundance so that would be
it's a different kind of challenge but
it is important
Jake but firstly congratulations and
well deserved and still severely
underrated thank you agreed
would you ever consider providing any
Standalone information on how you've
developed your conversational fluidity
and Brilliant questioning skills either
via a course video series book Etc I
think that the world would benefit from
people having more conversations like
you have on your podcast but not
everyone necessarily has the verbal
skills to facilitate them so yeah
communication Mastery is something that
I've thought about releasing as a course
I would maybe even bring in some guest
lecturers guys like my speech and
diction coach comedy coaches that I've
worked with and other good communicators
to maybe talk about their skills and
then try and create a syllabus
but I'm also concerned about getting out
over my skis you know like I I'm a good
communicator I've spent an awful lot of
time developing Real World skills from
the ground floor on how to have a
conversation
but I'm not trained so who the [__] am I
to release a course on it and this is
another reason you know this cynicism
thing that I'm railing against at the
moment
I want
modern wisdom and I want the people who
consume my content to be as positive as
possible because I feel in myself the
lack of confidence and the uncertainty
and the skepticism that I have around
things that I can do because I can hear
what the worst elements of the internet
will say if I try and do them so if I
try and release a course of
communication mastery
even if people care about it and even if
it adds value and even if it would be
good the fact that I'm not formally
trained in it and the fact that I am
going to be like trying to reverse
engineer something which I just stumbled
upon myself it's going to cause people
on the internet to have a vector of
attack for me which is going to mean
that they can say you shouldn't be
[__] doing this thing so well maybe I
don't do it it makes me reticent about
going to do it which is why being
positive encouraging people to go and
try and do something and see how it gets
on and [__] you know man like good
effort you tried to release that thing
and it maybe it was really really great
it adds tons of value I mean you know it
was it was all right and it wasn't so
good or whatever but like you had a
crack
I know like
presuming the best of people seems like
a really cool strategy and I that's what
I want I want more presumptions of
positivity uh the positivity presumption
Paradox
um but yeah I I would consider doing
that I would love to release it um again
need help course management building it
all the rest of it which I just can't do
on my own because I I have too much
stuff to do but I would love to release
it uh I just need to find someone that
can bring it to life and overcome the
skepticism and this is me one of the
first questions is like oh you me
advising some guy
just you know adventure and explore and
don't be worried about failing and here
is me speaking my fear of failure out
into the world the guy that's about to
hit a million subscribers on YouTube and
reaches like 25 million people a month
that fear of failure continues to track
with you it doesn't within domains that
you've already conquered but in domains
you're new in or you're moving into
it's going to be there so it's natural
like
even the people that you think that have
got all of their [__] sorted still feel
this stuff that should make you feel
more comfortable about not having your
[__] together as well
George Daniel
when you were younger did you have any
limit when you're younger did you have
any limiting beliefs and if you did did
you get over them how did you get over
them you are an inspiration thank you
George Daniel
um
I mean so many man my my sense of self
as a young
like a a teenage boy
was microscopically thin uh and I didn't
realize it at the time but I was
chronically unconfident here's the story
so I remember that I played Cricket that
was my
um pursuit of choice as a kid and
there would be times where because of
the type of player that I was I bowled
something called leg spin which is uh
probably the most complex style of
bowling in the sport of cricket and that
means that it's very dependent on the
conditions if the weather's not right if
the pitch isn't right if the game is at
the isn't it the right stage it's very
often that you would not be brought on
to bowl because it's safer to bring on a
different style of bowler which is going
to be more uh robust for the particular
features of the game that you're playing
and that would mean that a lot of the
time I would go and play a game
and then I wouldn't Bull and I would
sometimes not bat because I'd be batting
a little bit further down the order so
it's a
TFC a thanks for coming uh when you
don't bat and you don't bowl you
basically don't do anything in the game
apart from the field
and I would speak to the coaches from
the local County team that I was a part
of that was the one that was trying to
get me to move towards playing minor
counties playing Major counties going
into an academy I was on England's books
getting trained by their like wrist spin
Academy going down to Loughborough
University and stuff
and he would ring me on a Monday and say
how did he get on over the weekend and
I'd say ah man you know like everything
was it was I didn't Bowl I didn't part
you know like these things didn't happen
and he'd get frustrated because I hadn't
accumulated any experience
but I would feel relief
I would feel relief because I hadn't
had to face the potential of failure I
was so unconfident in my own abilities
that I would rather not have to face
potential failure
and inoculate myself from that by just
not being not entering in onto the arena
of play so yes I had an awful lot of
limiting beliefs and that rolled forward
into young adulthood it rolled forward
into relationships or forward into
business it rolled up fold into my sense
of self
it was I don't know like I
have had an awful lot of challenges with
regards to self-perception and
it's the whole Mosey thing man like I
wish I could come up with a different
quote that we didn't make go viral a ton
of times but
you need an undeniable stack of proof
that you are who you say you are like if
you want to be confident give yourself
some evidence outwork the self-doubt
that you've got outwork the Imposter
syndrome that you've got
you don't
if you're asking for confidence without
competence and evidence you're asking
for delusion
you need to have something that proves
to you that you are the person that you
say you are
iterating over time just doing things
trying new things going out there
putting yourself out there on the Arena
floor
seemed to work for me
will Palmer how do you deal with being
the outlier when chasing that dream job
while everyone else you know of going to
a nine to five in other words dealing
with the loneliness that will occur in
the pursuit of a life that you want my
situation
I resonate man I I feel for you
this is the price that you pay right
loneliness is a taxi you have to pay to
atone for a certain complexity of mind
or a complexity of life if you want to
have a life that's different to
everybody else you have to do things
that nobody else is doing like if you do
what everyone else does then you're
going to get what everyone else has got
and separating yourself out from the
pack this is why most people find things
difficult and this is where they stop
and this is why they don't win this is
the point it's the difficulty that
everybody else has to come over among a
ton of other difficulties they have to
be able to see it they have to have the
intention they have to have the
discipline to go after it they have to
have all of the different things in
place and then when it starts happening
and they realize I'll be easier I'd have
more of a Social Circle if I just stuck
about with my friends
that's also going to be one of the
hurdles that people have to overcome
accept and understand
you didn't expect it to be easy this is
what hard feels like on the other side
of this is something that you want
did you expect it to be easy
no
this is part of the hardness
lean into it lean into it the sign
that you are beginning to become more of
an outlier
is a signal that you're going along the
right path presuming that you're not an
outlier because you're addicted to drugs
or like beating up grannies on the
street
you're an outlier because you're working
harder you're an outlier because you're
taking a non-typical life path towards
something that you care about that is a
good thing it is not something that you
should see as a negative
Hamza El azawi when will you have
imangazi or Hamza Ahmed on the podcast
Chris would love to see you speak to
these men already had Hamza on the
podcast search Hamza Chris Williamson
and it'll come up I'm also going to
some create a retreat with Hamza in I
don't know where it is in a couple of
weeks time so we'll be together then
don't know what the recording I don't
think we are we're just chilling out
um Iman I voice noted back and forth
with him a couple of weeks ago and
that's going to happen I think in
November I'm in Dubai in November so I'm
going to have him on then
how do you go about desedating men while
not making them excessively dangerous
like burning down houses uh personally I
think it starts from education we need
to be encouraging boys to build
businesses participate in activities and
more extracurriculars every time I go to
a high school or college it's literally
girl up girl business girl that what
would be a good starting solution
very cool question these are smart
questions please comment more on the
YouTube
um how do you go about desedating men
while not making them excessively
dangerous it's tough it's tough because
the uh fuel the motivation that men have
to go and do these things can very
easily just be nudged toward anti-social
Behavior right like remember yobos
remember like anti like asbos there's
this thing called an anti-social
Behavior order that we had in the UK and
it was all these sort of
young working class and underclass guys
in their teens who would wear Nike Air
Max 90s and stand on the corner of
streets and just cause bother and they
were given these anti-social Behavior
orders as a uh
disincentive it was a way to stop this
from happening
I would love to see the stats around
that because I think that it'll have
gone through the floor it's really tough
I wouldn't disagree that encouraging
boys and and men to get involved in
progressing and pursuing things that are
genuinely going to make them feel
fulfilled is a very cool place to start
I would also love to see culture
re-pedestalize
men's achievement you know not every man
that achieves something is doing it from
a place of toxic tyrannical patriarchal
Advantage some guys just worked hard at
the thing and if you if you
disincentivize men from going after hard
things and contributing and achieving
what do you think are the sort of men
that you're going to get they're going
to be listless apathetic they're not
going to be interested in trying to
achieve anything and then you're going
to say well where are all of the Good
Men at why are these men not pulling
themselves up by their bootstraps why
are they leaving education and
employment at rates that we've never
seen one percent per month is 0.1 per
month is the retreat of men from the U.S
labor force since 1950 every single
month since 1950 0.1 percent of men have
retreated from the U.S labor force well
if you make the culture completely
unaligned and unforgiving to men who do
want to achieve things who do want to
acquire wealth or have ambition if you
say that that's part of some awful like
misogynistic [__] Vestige that's been
passed down from from previous
generations you're disincentivizing it
so what do you want do you want them to
be listless and and apathetic and
spending whatever it is thousands of
hours per year playing video games while
smoking weed like Nicholas everstat
taught us I don't want that
but on the flip side you are going to
have some guys that are going to go and
do mean things if they're you know
spirited and and full of energy and
vigor
they're gonna go and do other things so
balancing those two is tough but I would
say that we are way way too far into the
world of sedation than we are into the
world of animation
Jordan
Hewitt congratulations are there any
plans on getting Andy for Zeller on the
show Andy frizzella is the guy who
founded first form and also created 75
hard for the people that are familiar
with those things uh We've Spoken a good
bit he listens to the show uh he's very
complimentary on Instagram and has sent
me some really nice messages
um I think we've talked about getting
him on when he comes through Austin so
at some point yep
have you considered bringing on the
channel a scientist expert that you
don't necessarily feel completely
aligned with in terms of views just to
listen to a different perspective I do I
try to bring on as many of these people
as possible uh Richard Betts from the
ipcc he is a lead author on a turn of
the intergovernmental panels on climate
change papers uh he came on not a
million years ago he was really
interesting David packman he came on he
got flamed in the comments he didn't
really have a particularly good episode
but
he uh he's somebody that a lot of the
audience disagrees with and would
disagree with
um
I try my hardest to bring on people I
mean I've had a couple recently of of
academics that are very left-leaning uh
but we they have such a a unique spin
that is apolitical on whatever their
academic area is that we don't actually
get into maybe some of the more
squirrely World Views that we would
diverge on so yeah I do try
fantivity Colton have you ever been on a
date worse than the massage date with
Zoe if so what happened I just watched
your Season of Love Island to get some
context about some things you talk about
okay yeah so
um no probably not but then I also
haven't been on many dates on TV I
actually know [__] that I have the other
the other TV show that I did take me out
I think that one might have been more
Awkward the first TV show that I did I
jumped off a boat in the middle of the
ocean when they didn't have insurance
for me to jump off the boat because the
date that I was on was that boring and
then the girl that I was on that date
with sold a story about me when I went
on love Island the police were called on
my date with Chris [__] you weren't
even there I'd left I'd gone to an after
party I was with some cool people and
then she sold a story about me that I
told her the only reason that she knew
about the police coming was because I
told her and the only reason that the
police came was because I woke up on the
central reservation of tenerife's
largest Motorway having lost my phone in
my wallet like it wasn't because I'd
caused some Havoc somewhere I'd fallen
asleep on a central reservation of a
Motorway
anyway yeah that was worse that one was
worse
I can't remember the girl's name
can't remember her name and it kind of
looked a bit like Zoe weird
um some was it physiognomy or whatever
it's called uh where like the way that
somebody looks determines their
personality I think that's the way it
works anyway yeah it was awkward
um
Jensen McKay hey man first of all
congrats on 900 000 Subs been watching
you since your podcast with Kristoff wow
that's old my question is as a 19 year
old you've been watching me since you
were 15. cool as a 19 year old heading
to University in September what is the
best way of finding people as
like-minded as me within the first week
of freshers struggled a bit during
schools I used to live in a rural area
P.S what was your freshest week like how
did you survive it many thanks okay so
my freshers week was
ruthless it was 2006. it was Larry
British Laut drink culture uh I had
found a group of housemates I lived in a
flat with a bunch of degenerates that
were fantastic really really great to go
to UNI with but uni was second third
fourth on the list of what everybody was
there to do
um
finding people that are like you during
freshers I would say and this is
something that I wish I'd done more of
attend more of the groups and societies
and classes just join all of them like I
remember when I went to UNI and I
thought Ultimate Frisbee sound super
lame I don't want to go and do Ultimate
Frisbee
um I'm just gonna go to the gym and get
big with the boys and I again it was a
safety net for me because it meant that
it was routinized and it was something
that I knew I was going to get Social
validation from I remember in my mid-20s
I looked back and thought why the [__]
didn't I go and do Ultimate Frisbee that
sounds awesome like Ultimate Frisbee
sounds really cool so I would join as
many different societies as you can
expose yourself to all of those
different groups and just talk talk to
people and talk about what you're
interested in don't talk about what you
think they're interested in because if
you talk about what somebody else if you
talk about what you think somebody else
is interested in you are going to get
friends around you who aren't keen on
you they're keen on the role that you
play they don't like you they like the
person that you think they're like the
person that they think that you are
that's not who you want to be you're
going to end up surrounded by a
community of people who don't have your
interests and who you have to play a
LARPing caricature of yourself to just
be around
be yourself do lots of different things
expose yourself to as many people as
possible
during fresh is the best thing to ask
someone is hey man what's your name what
course are you doing what Halls are you
in you can open up for the first four
weeks of term you can say that to a
thousand people
see the ones that are interesting make
friends good luck
fabulin how long did it take you to
become comfortable recording yourself in
front of a camera I tried this for the
first time recently and had no clue how
hard it was to explain a coherent
thought without stumbling over your own
words any tips on how to get better at
self podcasting I'm glad I'm not glad
that you were traumatized by it but I am
glad that you have felt the discomfort
and I remember
the first few times that we started
doing solo down the pipe monologue
things like this
it is that hole there that black void
with the lens in the middle of it that
looks like an eye
is a terrifying thing to look at it is
so
unforgiving and dark and you just
stare at it and it stares back and it
just expects you to say things and
there's no one there to
give you positive feedback or tell you
that you're doing it right or that
you're doing it wrong or that you should
say more or say less so it's time to
shut up or
it's really difficult
um I haven't spent all that much time
doing solo stuff I've spent a lot of
time talking to other people and I think
that my brain struggles to uh
distinguish between the conversations
I've had where there's been a person
there and now this thing which is where
there's no person there
the
easiest ways the best ways to get better
at self-podcasting I think are to do
what I'm doing here which is to have a
conversation a one-way conversation with
prompts prompt can come from you you
could maybe even use chat gbt to say
um give me 20 interesting but accessible
and easy questions to answer whilst
practicing doing a podcast on my own and
I bet it would create some awesome
awesome ideas for that
uh but it's tough and I would be tempted
to try and do podcasting before you do
monologues because this is the final
frontier like even when you're vlogging
right you know like the Mike Thurston
style here I am I'm in Dubai in my
jaguar or whatever the [__] it is that
he drives now
um
that this prompts going on oh look at
this this is a cool cup of coffee and
I'm here with my friends and I've got
the whatever
this is the final boss man this no
distraction silent room you in a lens
it's super difficult and this skill is
going to become more and more important
friends I've had have applied for jobs
where they've had to submit video
applications and if you've never had to
sit bunk and just put your phone in
front of you and say hi guys my name is
Chris and I'm really excited for the job
opportunity at IBM here are why you
should recruit me and this is a blah
blah blah blah
if you don't have that in the tank
you're going to be behind and if you do
have it in the tank you're going to find
an advantage and even if you don't need
it it's going to make you a better
Communicator so I highly recommend
learning it
Ahmed zobar surosh from Afghanistan [__]
yeah let's go
loving your content can't thank you
enough mate thank you very much my
number one Afghani uh fan uh question
how to find balance between time spent
on being the least educated person in
the room and the most educated both are
necessary good point and
um plays off the back of Alex halmosi's
comment around more people are kept poor
by their egos than get rich off them
basically if you're able to maintain an
ego it's because you're in a room where
you're always the richest or the
smartest or the most accomplished which
means that you're in a room which is too
small make your room bigger make the
people that you hang around with more
successful which will make your ego
smaller because comparatively with them
you're useless
um
finding a balance I to be honest I
wouldn't agree that you need to be the
most educated person in the room
ever basically I think that maintaining
being a stupid person the most stupid
person in the room is a good idea I mean
I've managed to make a career out of
being the dumbest person in a
conversation 640 times and it seems to
have worked okay for me
it is good to educate other people about
things that you're a specialist in but
just continue to find people who you
admire who you respect who you think
have got a growth mindset and are
interested and genuinely curious and
just allow them to teach you about all
of the cool [__] that they know and then
in response you can teach them about the
good stuff that you know
there is no better way to learn than
that and that's why Austin at the moment
is phenomenal because there are so many
people that are super super smart
in different domains so you can be the
guy that knows about evolutionary
psychology but they know about AI risk
or they know about meteorology or they
know about whatever
say car
congrats to us all
right my question is how do you just do
it like how do you stop overthinking and
take action that is quite an interesting
question for crispot
my quest my answer would be that you
just need to commit to doing one thing
narrow the domain as I said earlier on
stop distracting yourself with lots of
different things
what the [__] is he trying to respond to
this crispot how do you just do it like
how do you stop overthinking and just
take action I don't know but I'm pretty
sure it involves a lot of swearing and a
few shots of whiskey
I
crispot confident bot over there just
getting out over his skis poor guy
um
stop overthinking and just take action
commit to one domain at a time the
reason that you're feeling overwhelmed
is because you're trying to do too much
at once you're trying to optimize your
sleep and your hydration and your
training and your learning and your
career and your relationships one thing
one thing focus on that get really good
at doing that one thing and then move on
to the next one you have periods you can
periodize your life right one month to
three months each little block once
you've completed it then you move on to
the next one you can even plan it in
advance check in every couple of weeks
see how you're getting on
they go
I fuzzy my question is what advice would
you give to someone with disabilities
and deformities to boost their
confidence and self-esteem so I've
basically gave up on life because of my
anxiety and depression your videos have
been a big help and I want to say thank
you thank you very much for watching
look I
need to be able to identify where I'm at
the boundaries of my competence and I
think that this is it I
wholeheartedly believe that there is a
strategy and that there will be but I'm
going to be pulling something out of my
ass if I try and give it to you I
respect massively the fact that you're
listening to channels like this and
presumably other guests and similar
people that come on here and you're
exposing yourself to the right kind of
content when it comes to getting really
tactical with it
I would be bullshitting you if I said
that I had a solution however
I am confident that you have the right
mindset to be able to find a solution
and I wish you all the best
Duncan disorderly how many man hours of
preparation do you do for each guest you
seem to have a good set of knowledge and
ask insightful questions just seems like
a lot of work goes into each episode so
yeah
it is there is a lot of work that goes
into each episode
I'm gonna ask Chris but see if he knows
how much work I do
um he'll probably say that I'd do it in
a line of cocaine in five minutes ha I
wish I could tell you how many man hours
I put into each episode but the truth is
I don't really keep track I just know
that I'm always doing something to
prepare for the next episode whether
it's researching the guest reading up on
the topic just thinking of interesting
questions I'm always doing something to
make sure I'm ready for the next episode
that
that's like halfway between confidence
confidence bought and cookbot uh it's
usually about a day
um so on and off listening to the guest
but it'll be spread out over a period of
time right usually takes around about a
day or so
um sometimes less you know especially if
it's someone that I know that
um the topic inside out
it can be a lot less
um but for the guys that are new and a
lot of this stuff recently has been new
like learning about uh who've I had this
week
video games
um
uh not bullying
God damn it
body dysmorphia men's muscle dysmorphia
and something else as well uh
that takes a lot of work so
I'm prepared because it's what works and
I'm following the strategy that I used
to follow before I knew all of the
things that I know
and now I still follow the strength same
strategy even though I know a lot more
things which means I'm usually really
really well prepared for each episode
but I hope that it comes across and I
hope that it it makes the listening
experience good because I'm not
fumbling around and struggling for
talking points I want to keep it you
know if you guys are going to dedicate
an hour and a half of your time to me
three times a week I want it to be high
bang for your buck I want it to you to
come away and think wow that was a
really well structured and great and it
did there was no lulls in there that
didn't need to be in there and um
yeah I hope that it makes for a um
High Roi podcast
Roger page thank you for all the
wonderful educational content you have
produced thank you my question is when
will you be adding video content to
Spotify this is a question that we've
got
a lot and I don't know to be honest it's
a bit of an effort to make this
transition for some structural reasons
behind the scenes of how you
create the audio you rip the audio from
the video that would then distribute to
places like apple podcasts and Stitcher
and Google podcasts and Amazon that
wouldn't be using the video so we'd need
a video version for YouTube a video
version for megaphone to upload to
Spotify and then a different audio
version that would go across everything
else there'd be three different versions
of each episode three times a week
and it's just a huge lift
um if we change the way that we do ads I
really don't want to start doing
mid-roll ads because I think it destroys
the listening process but maybe we're
gonna have to if we want to do video on
Spotify
so it's just it's a it's a mess it's
it's a little bit of a mess at the
moment we have just changed hosting from
libsyn to Spotify I announced this on
Twitter the other week and
um that's gone really well so far
but as of yet not gonna happen
maybe at some point in future not sure
yet right that is an hour and 45. I
appreciate all of you 1 million next
which will be wild I have some plans and
I will see if I can pull them off in the
meantime like I say if you are the sort
of person that asks these kinds of
questions if you enjoyed this sort of
discussion which I know that you do
comment more on the YouTube I would
appreciate it the real world of the
internet that this show is going to
continue to push out into more
those people need to understand what a
well-balanced thoughtful interesting
meaningful conversation is and it is you
who can contribute to that and you set
the tone especially if we're going to
talk about releasing a Discord server
and community and all this sort of stuff
I need to feel confident that the people
that are the most reasonable that all of
the ones that submit thousands of
questions on each of these q and A's are
the ones that are going to pipe up and
if you do post something that's stupid
then you're gonna get a ban
anyway I'll see you next time